so this is the second part in a two-part
webinar the first one was a few weeks
ago with our studio server Pro and then
this one is about SHINee server Pro
these webinars are slightly different
than some of the other webinars that
we've done in that they're geared
towards administration of our products
and they are you know we'll be referring
to the admin guides I'm frequently so
this one's about Chinese server Pro and
I'm really excited to do it and I've got
a lot to go through so we should just
get started
to give you a brief background of our
product stack for those of you that are
not maybe not that familiar with our
studio products we have an IDE we have
this thing called SHINee which is what
we're talking about today and then we
develop all these open source packages
that are freely available to the
community what is SHINee SHINee is a web
application framework for our you can
turn your analyses into interactive web
applications and you don't need to know
HTML CSS or JavaScript in order to build
these this is a hello world script
that's on our main page SHINee our
studio comm you can see that you have
some interactive controls you can add
some nice features here and then you can
interact with this app this app is built
with two pieces one is the UI script
that defines the user interface and then
the other one is server dot R which
defines the actual functionality of the
app itself for example histogram is in
here and as well which is right here as
well as like the rug plot and the
density lines so this is a shiny app we
have a lot of lectures and discussions
about shiny apps we're not going to be
really talking about developing shiny
apps today we're going to be talking
about hosting those shiny apps using
shiny server pro the
a little bit different about these
webinars than the previous ones that we
did we've done is these really are
focused on our professional products and
we're doing that because if you're going
to have an administrative team managing
the products you're probably going to be
using a professional products so a lot
of the features that we'll be talking
about today are specifically Pro related
products and I'm not going to
differentiate between Pro and
open-source here and I'm going to I will
solely be referring to Pro features
without making that distinction so every
shiny application requires a shiny
server on the back end shiny server Pro
is the product that we use to help us
secure performance and modern monitor
resource utilization you know and really
make you know your applications
available to everyone in your
organization or your enterprise we
oftentimes get the question was the
difference between shiny and shiny
server it's a really good question
I can relate because I had the same
question at first I was being developed
shiny is open-source package that is
used to develop applications and it's
used to build these responsive and
powerful applications shiny server Pro
is professional software that you that
you use to host the applications and
it's designed to scale protect and
manage and secure your environment